you know the idea that great whites are  these malicious killing machines roving  the shorelines looking for some swimmer  to chomp on is just pure fiction you  know anytime there is a human attack  stay calm it's just a case of mistaken  identity are you guys  you might explain to me what it is  you're doing with bull sharks and  containment my company is one of the  leading producers of intelligence  enhancers that can actually alter the  genetic structure of the brain their  problem solving learning how to learn  like you actually think you can get the  same results in human beings Oh  potential is greater than anyone sees it  just needs to be unleashed let me show  you we can all be gods  or monsters  I've never seen him act this way  or looser pressure what does that mean  [Music]  whatever you created here is teeth and  muscle and killer instinct  you  you